me
you know he human
we cannot control her to breathe Uli's
Scarlett Johansson goes to the show easy
too
we saved you a non-state other future
for practical I got my wish in an x-ray
how many fingers am i oh my god [ __ ] you
needed me at the kill me and now
right behind you major
Scarlett Johansson goes to the show
we're shooting the shelling sequence
that is very iconic from the anime and
from the manga where the majors
character come to life
everything you see of the skeleton in
the showing city the real skeleton so we
did as much practically as we could this
is the majors going this is actually
scarlet pipe so that was one of the
first things we did was find out how
tall scarlet was and then scale the
model to her
so because we had such fantastic designs
up front we were able to go through and
basically break this down into all
different components and I think there
ended up being about 1,400 individual
pieces and they all need to mesh
together and fit together perfectly
we've essentially created an internal
skeleton and then basically put a muscle
layer around the outside of that it's
just in a slow truck we had another body
as well that we brought out of a white
liquid and that was really just skin
layer that went over top so it's all
about adding these layers and watching
the layers build up through the produce
the actual shelling sequence is one of
the ultimate moments and goes from the
shell so getting the opportunity to
actually a part of us has been massive
as exciting for me to make a version of
that echoes the originals and felt like
it was actually happening
you
you